en vídeos anteriores vimos que una
pelota con masa m que está rotando en un
círculo con radio r y con una rapidez be
va a tener lo que llamamos momento
angular y el símbolo que usamos para
momento angular es una l mayúscula y la
cantidad de momento angular que va a
tener va a ser igual a la masa de la
pelota por la rapidez de esta pelota
esto básicamente es la magnitud del
momento y esto lo multiplicamos por el
radio del círculo en el que se está
moviendo esta pelota y esto nos va a dar
el momento angular de esta pelota que se
está moviendo en un círculo lo que está
muy bien y es bueno de saber pero no
siempre vamos a tener una pelota
moviéndose en círculo y vamos a querer
conocer el momento angular por ejemplo
en lugar de tener esto vamos a tener
esto en lugar de tener una pelota que va
alrededor de un círculo vamos a tener
una barra que va a girar en uno de sus
extremos
con masa m y radio r y toda la barra va
a girar en un círculo y digamos que el
extremo derecho va a estar moviéndose
con una rapidez de igual que como lo
hacía la pelota y aquí la pregunta es
esta barra también tendrá momento
angular que sea igual a m por b por r y
no no va a ser así ya que la pelota
teníamos que toda la masa iba a viajar
con una rapidez y toda la masa se
encontraba en la parte exterior de este
círculo
en otras palabras toda esta masa estaba
viajando con un radio r pero para esta
barra aquella masa que se encuentra en
este extremo es la que va a estar
viajando con un radio r lo demás de la
masa como por ejemplo la que está aquí
va a trazar un círculo pero este círculo
que traza no va a tener un radio r va a
tener un valor menor a r así que como
determinamos el momento angular de un
objeto cuya
está distribuida de forma que algo de la
masa esté más cercana al eje y otra
parte de la masa esté más lejana al eje
y esto es lo que vamos a ver en este
vídeo la aproximación que usan los
físicos para esto y casi siempre es el
mismo decimos bueno tengo la fórmula
para el momento angular de una sola
partícula viajando alrededor de un
círculo con un mismo radio ahora
imaginemos que nuestro objeto continuo
está compuesto por muchísimos por
muchísimas masas que están viajando con
un solo radio si descompongo este objeto
continuo en piezas individuales si me lo
imagino que está separado en todas estas
piezas pues si yo encuentro el momento
angular para cada una de estas piezas
individuales y las sumo todas voy a
obtener el momento angular total de este
objeto completo vamos a hacerlo el
momento angular de un pedazo de este
objeto pues va a ser igual
de este pedacito lo voy a escribir como
m pero no es la masa completa solo va a
ser la masa de este pequeño pedazo
multiplicado por el radio en que se
encuentra para aclarar esto vamos a
referirnos como pedazo 1 a esta masa
aquí tenemos m 1 v1 y r 1 y esto va a
ser el momento angular de este pedazo 1
y si lo hacemos para este pedazo 2 de
acá el momento angular de este pedazo 2
se da de m2 por b 2 por r 2 ahora tengan
en mente que todas estas veces van a ser
diferentes la rapidez en el extremo
derecho va a ser mayor
la rapidez de este pedazo 1 y la rapidez
del pedazo que está más cercano al eje
pues va a ser menor ya que va a estar
trazando círculos más pequeños en la
misma cantidad de tiempo de lo que lo
hacen estas piezas que están más
exteriores y quizá este punto les
preocupe y piensen que va a ser muy
difícil de calcular vamos a tener que
sumar todas estas piezas y cada una va a
tener una rapidez diferente y radios
diferentes cómo vamos a hacer eso bueno
tengan paciencia ahorita lo vamos a ver
aquí algo mágico va a ocurrir imaginen
que sumamos todos estos pedazos aquí
sólo dibuje dos pero imagínense que hay
una cantidad infinita de pedazos de masa
aquí lo cual nos parecerá que hace todo
más difícil pero no se preocupen
imagínense entonces que dividimos esto
en una cantidad infinita de pedazos de
masa y consideramos el momento angular
individual de cada una de ellas y se dan
cantidades muy pequeñas ya que ésta
me va a ser una parte infinitesimal de
la masa del objeto y si las sumamos que
va a pasar sumamos las m por b por r de
todos los pedazos de masa que tenemos
aquí esto va a ser el momento angular
total de la barra
esto es m 1 por b 1 por r 1 + m2 por b 2
por r 2 y así sucesivamente para la
cantidad infinita de fragmentos de masa
que tenemos aquí no lo podemos escribir
porque es una cantidad infinita de
elementos y ahora cómo podemos resolver
todo esto en física queremos usar un
método más inteligente para resolver
todas estas sumas infinitas y esta forma
es si escribimos el igual a la suma de m
por b por r tenemos el problema de que
cada masa tiene un ave diferente si
factor hizo cosas de esta suma me va a
ayudar a simplificar las cosas pero aquí
no puedo factorizar las erres porque
todas las masas se encuentran en radios
porque todas las masas se encuentran a
distancias diferentes del eje y además
cada masa tiene una rapidez diferente de
las demás pero recuerden que aquí nos
gusta escribir las cantidades en
términos de variables angulares ya que
las variables angulares van a ser las
mismas para todos los puntos de esta
masa así que aunque cada punto de esta
barra que rota tiene una velocidad
diferente todos estos puntos van a tener
la misma velocidad angular o mega y esto
es algo clave que vamos a hacer aquí
esto va a ser la suma de m pero en lugar
de escribir ven voy a usar la velocidad
angular o mega r por omega recuerden que
para algo que rota en un círculo la
rapidez va a ser igual a ere por omega y
esto es lo que estamos sustituyendo aquí
la rapidez de cualquier punto aquí va a
ser el radio de ese punto x
por la rapidez angular de toda la barra
de aquí que está rotando en un círculo y
esto aún lo tengo que multiplicar por la
última r de aquí esto era b que
sustituimos por r omega y esto lo
multiplicamos por r nos va a quedar que
l es la suma de m por r al cuadrado por
omega y esto está muy bien ya que la
omega es la misma para todos los puntos
en esta barra todas las masas
individuales van a viajar a la misma
velocidad angular así que podemos
factorizar esto fuera de la zona ya que
se pueden imaginar que todos estos
términos de aquí van a tener una omega
las actualizamos y las sacamos fuera de
la suma esto es igual a la suma de m por
r al cuadrado y para hacerlo más claro
ponemos paréntesis
todo esto está multiplicado por omega
que justamente la factory zados y quizá
ustedes no se sientan impresionados por
esto no es la gran cosa ya que de todas
maneras tenemos una suma
está aquí y qué voy a hacer con eso pues
no tienen que hacer nada justo es aquí
donde ocurre la magia noten que tenemos
la suma de todas las emes por r al
cuadrado y recuerdan que era m por r al
cuadrado m por r al cuadrado es el
momento de inercia de una masa puntual y
si sumo todas las m por r al cuadrado
pues voy a tener el momento de inercia
de toda la barra
así que encontramos una manera bastante
práctica de escribir el momento angular
de un objeto que es el momento de
inercia del objeto y mayúscula
multiplicada por la velocidad angular
del objeto y esta es una fórmula genial
que tiene sentido porque si piensan en
el momento regular el momento regular t
es igual a la masa por la rapidez y si
ustedes me dicen que quieren determinar
el momento angular sin hacer toda esta
reducción de aquí pues podríamos decir
que el momento angular es igual a pues
voy a reemplazar la masa por el momento
de inercia que es la más angular o la
inercia angular y reemplazo la rapidez
con la rapidez angular y así obtengo
esta fórmula tiene sentido porque estoy
reemplazando todas las variables
regulares con su contraparte angular y
así obtenemos el momento angular de un
objeto que está en rotación así que si
ustedes tienen uno
extendido como masa y que está
homogéneamente distribuida en todo el
objeto si tomamos el momento de inercia
de ese objeto y lo multiplicamos por su
rapidez angular tendremos un momento
angular por ejemplo si esta barra tiene
una masa de 3 kilogramos y esta masa
está distribuida homogéneamente y
digamos que el radio de este objeto es
de 2 metros es la distancia del eje
hasta el borde externo de la barra y
digamos que la velocidad angular de este
objeto es de 10 radiales por segundo
podemos calcular el momento angular de
esta barra diciendo que el momento
angular de este objeto es igual al
momento de inercia y el momento de
inercia de una barra que rota en uno de
sus extremos va a ser igual a un tercio
de m por l al cuadrado y esto lo
multiplicamos por la velocidad angular
del objeto así que sustituimos
cantidades aquí y nos queda que el
momento angular de este objeto
un tercio m que es de tres kilogramos
por l que es la longitud que es de dos
metros al cuadrado y lo multiplicamos
por la rapidez angular de 10 radiales
por segundo lo que nos dará un momento
angular de 40 kilogramos metro al
cuadrado por segundo en resumen si
tenemos una masa puntual donde toda la
masa rota con el mismo radio y queremos
encontrar el momento angular la forma
más fácil de encontrarla es con la
fórmula m por b por r sin embargo si
tenemos un objeto cuya masa está
distribuida de manera que diferentes
puntos del objeto van a tener un radio
diferente la forma más sencilla de
encontrar el momento angular de este
objeto es usando la fórmula y o'mega
donde y es el momento de inercia del
objeto iomega es la velocidad angular de
este objeto